welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and one division episode 3 just
made the best argument yet that the true
villain of this series
the one lurking in the shadows is wanda
herself seriously she just
walked up to geraldine slash monica did
that creepy ass head
tilt that she always does before she
wrecked somebody then she just made her
friend
disappear and even vision knew to keep
his distance from this twilight zone
anthony fremont rosemary's baby miyapero
actually wanda serenades her babies with
their own lullaby insukovian
that we were able to translate for you
it's hidden meaning plus these other
creepy undertones paint wanda
not as a complete victim of her
fantasies but as the orchestrator of
them
look folks there's a lot of clues
pointing in a lot of different
directions but i'm gonna cut through all
of them in this video to lay out the
simple truth of this series
that everything bad about westview could
be wanda's doing so
wanda tells geraldine i'm a twin i had a
brother
his name was pedro whoa i detect a hint
of an accent that wanda just kind of
dropped an infinity war
what follows is a sokovian lullaby and
when you watch this with brazilian
portuguese subtitles
lyrics are added and they translate to
[Music]
interesting while experiencing labor
pains wanda's home does become
full of light a light that blows the
fuses of all of west view it even
disables the car of dr
nielsen preventing his escape small
towns
you know so hard to
escape come to think it probably also
disabled herb
saw stopping him from mindlessly cutting
into the wall trying to break down the
barriers of this reality
you could see these lyrics as a kind of
confession by wanda that she
premeditated all this
burying babies with vision is exactly
what she wanted in episode 2 the town of
westview chanted for the children as if
subliminally willing wanda
into motherhood but here it sounds like
this is something she has wanted for a
while
my heart became a home parallels the
westview town slogan from the billboard
home is where you make it westview is a
kind of home that wanda manifested with
her reality warping powers and by the
end of episode 3
wanda seems very much in control of this
domain she
coldly ejects geraldine agnes herb and
dr nielsen seem afraid of rattling this
cage that they're in with wanda
she came here because we're all stop it
and i pointed out that agnes here uses
the same words as the ones repeated
again and again by mrs hart in episode
one when she was suffering that
breakdown stop it
stop it stop it this moment actually
told us a lot about wanda
mr hart shouted his questions and then
suddenly he starts choking some people
even think wanda may have been waving
her fingers to cause that to happen i'm
not so sure about that yet but
wanda does wait unsettlingly long before
doing anything vision is looking to
wanda for permission to act
in fact mrs hearts stop it transition
from a playful skull to her husband
into a desperate plea for help to wanda
to stop this choking and save her
husband
finally juana gives vision permission to
save him but she uses a heartless tone
similar to the one she took with monica
vision help him
vision help him how very willy wonka
stop don't come back
wanda doesn't give a wonder the
about these people
dottie called it i've heard things about
you i assure you i don't mean anyone
any harm i don't believe you
and then each time reality has broken
too much wanda abruptly edits and
patches it from saying no to the
beekeeper and rewinding the previous
scene to cutting off vision questioning
their reality with a real sloppy jump
cut i think something's wrong here
london
now sword seems to be giving wanda the
benefit of the doubt thinking someone
else
must be doing this to wanda wanda
who's doing this sure there are other
sides pointing in that direction
like agnes is definitely up to something
with her suspicious mentions of her
husband ralph and devils in the details
the grim reaper's helmet
shows up in the episode two animated
intro others say the hexagons and that
beekeeper could be connected
to aim and of course the many hydra
easter eggs from the strucker watch to
the hydra
soak a nod to the hydra mind control
soap that coulson ranted about in an
episode of agents of shield but think
about what's more likely that one of
these things is revealed to be the big
bad
rendering all the other clues pointless
red herrings or that
all of these things are manifestations
of the various influences
on the one threat that we have tangible
evidence of doing harm to this world
wanda maximoff but before i continue
thank you to bang energy for sponsoring
this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces and it
contains
300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has zero calories
yet it tastes really good with over 20
different flavors to choose from
one of those great flavors is peach
mango and how to describe peach mango
well
imagine a major league baseball pitcher
throwing a peach in your mouth followed
by
a curveball mango two bites of delicious
fruit with a ton of energy
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order at bang energy.com
when you use the code newrockstars25
yeah there you can buy cans of bang
energy including their sweet tea and
keto coffee flavors you can also get
clothing and fitness supplements all
kinds of stuff to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
new rockstars25
sword may assume that wanda is an
avenger only holding a town hostage at
the behest and under the control of some
darker force but
look at sword's name sentient weapon
observation and response department
echoing the way secretary ross described
hulk and thor
and yes scarlet witch as weapons of mass
destruction
if i misplaced a couple of 30 megaton
nukes you can bet there'd be
consequences
the commercials we've seen so far are
telling a story actually show runner
jack shaffer confirmed this
and that story is the evolution of
wanda's trauma a stark
toaster that beeps just like the stark
bomb that never detonated and
traumatized her in pietro
a strucker watch for the hydra scientist
who experimented on her hydra soap for
this organization considering her
a goddess in an age of miracles and by
mentioning her dead brother pietro wanda
finally hints at what this is all about
with pietro and with vision her
family was taken from her and by
manifesting vision alive once more
and these children wanda hopes to
replace that which she has lost
the question remains of course how she
is doing this maybe via a partnership
with the witch
agnes and whomever agnes serves a
classic
deal with the devil imagine this
scenario agnes comes to wanda with
promises to resurrect her beloved
synthezoid and give her an opportunity
to birth
children children that will secretly be
hell spawned using pieces of mephisto's
soul
how using dark magic what are they going
to do exactly what they did in the
comics bring in the dark hole the book
of the dead well maybe
but this is a tv show maybe they're
going to use some other cursed object
like agnes's television set in her west
view home
that's why everything is taking the form
of classic sitcoms and when wanda takes
this spell by the reigns it could have
accidentally enveloped the entire town
in this pocket reality based on the
nature of that source
whatever the explanation wanda is more
in control than we thought
she made a faustian bargain for vision
and kids and in doing so
she doomed this town maybe even the
universe in multiverse
that is how you get a reality flipping
villain in multiverse of madness
when a mother realizes her newborns were
brought into this world by the devil
she's gonna flip out and don't tell me
rosemary's baby is not connected because
in addition to that lullaby the closing
credits end with the sound of this woman
crying
and this sounds almost exactly like the
terrifying shrieks
in the music when rosemary sees her hell
spawn
[Music]
you can support this channel by getting
our new latest obsession shirt an
unusual couple it's got secret easter
eggs revealed via ar
at newarkstersmerch.com selling out fast
follow me on instagram
ea vos follow new rockstar subscribe for
breakdowns of the many many questions
you have about one division thank you
for watching
[Music]
you